(rock music)
- [Voiceover] When we last
met Princess Brittania
our lady had imbibed a bit
too much tavern brandy.
- Where am I?
- [Voiceover] And today's
sunlight shed light
on some less than noble traces.
- No, no, no.
No, no, no.
(bells)
- Good morning my precious petal.
- Fuck.
- I hope this doesn't
offend your royal palate
but I made you cups.
- Yeah, I have the stomach thing
so this will go straight through me.
- I brought herbal remedies for that.
- Thanks a lot.
- Sit, blossom,
and while I have you here
can I go over some jokes with you
for my routine this eve?
(clears throat) Knock ye knock.
- You hear that?
- Click, click, click, click.
- Yup that's the drawbridge.
I better get rollin'.
They don't wait for me.
- Call for me?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Last night was ravishing.
- Yeah that's a word.
(slow music)
(chuckles)
- Beat that Todd.
- [Voiceover] Life you know.
Full circle.
You're hilarious.
(laughter)
(jazz music)
(horn)
- Message for Princess Brittania!
- OK, yeah.
- To my beautiful, blushing princess
I cannot dig your mode again.
Remember from last night.
We made love last night.
I'm talking about we made love last night.
- OK, thank you.
- But there's more.
- I absolutely do not want to hear it.
- Ah well OK.
(slow music)
- Ah, Brittania!
Come.
Time for the performance.
- Big event?
In public?
Lots of witnesses?
- Yes.
Jesterca requests our royal presence.
Oh yes.
(laughter)
- Daddy, I don't want to.
- And then I stated that's no sword
that's my penis.
(laughter)
That's my time.
Thank you so much.
Draw the bore.
Tip your wench.
Oh, have fun following that.
- Incredible.
- I like him a lot.
- Tight tights.
Please don't touch me.
- Oh, no.
A lot please.
- (sighing) I call this
the muse sits before me.
The muse sits before me.
I can still smell the sweat on your neck
through my nostrils
as they juggle their desires.
- Thank you, Jesterca,
for that wonderful
experimental performance?
- Yes, thank you.
(indistinct talking)
- Hello, lover.
- Can we do this later?
- How about a little
now and a little later?
- Fuck!
- If you insist.
- No.
I'm sorry.
Last night was my bad.
I shouldn't have slept with you.
- You didn't want to
prick spindles with me?
- No.
Last night was weird.
I saw my ex, got drunk, found a shoe.
We'll talk.
We'll probably won't talk about this.
(sobbing)
- Oh, oh, oh. (laughter)
Delightful.
- Oh.
A sad jester.
How original.
- Brittania broke my heart.
- Sounds like someone
might want to take revenge
on such a dark soul.
- Yeah.
Yeah, maybe.
- Tell me everything.
(rock music)